j'ai toujours vécu pour les 400 mètres
d'une course mais les temps changent
aujourd'hui je super j'aurai toujours
une place dans ton coeur ti brian j'ai
un cadeau pour toi c'est ton papa qui me
l'a donné
aujourd'hui je te le donne c'est très
important
ses portes protéger
quoi qu'il arrive
on y est les dames
et maintenant
on peut aller aussi vite qu'on peut on
n'échappe pas son passé et le mien
viens de me rattraper ça faisait un bail
tonnes
le mec qu'on affrontait un super voleur
un à face à un pilote de haut niveau
c'est qui
jacob est le frère de daman toute ta vie
tu t'es battu pour être plus rapide que
dans plus malin que d'hommes plus fort
que dame
mais est ce que tu pourrais le tuer
parce que je suis prête si tu lui aussi
[Musique]
rien n'est plus puissant que l'amour de
la famille mais quand il se transforme
en haine
rien n'est plus dangereux c'est
peut-être perdu d'avancé mais on y va
ensemble
je sais que je te suivra jusqu'à la mort
à nous de jouer
dis-moi pas que c'est une pontiac fiero
équipé d'un moteur roquettes
impressionnant je sais non non c'est pas
impressionnants jeux gonflables
[Musique]
je suis venu pour démolir qui frère tu
vas regretter
c'est mon territoire
ils ont un avion et m'en tiens toi me
dites pas que tu penses à ce que je
pense y a pas de fonds
oh non il est au fond
bon
on
les gars
surprise cool votre club privé
[Musique]